hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ihr
habt die moral zu stäbchen schon gesehen
heute gibt es sie und zwar mal mist auf
einem kanal wirklich zuerst einmal in
diesem video gibt's ein paar
grundlegende basics ich mache den reiz
aber als ich lege den ingwer ein und was
man genug
ja und dann rollen wir drei verschiedene
sorten und zwar gibt's nigiri maki und
was haben noch im feld aufrollen
genau ich werde jetzt zuerst aber mit
dem ingwer anfang denn der muss
eingelegt werden und dafür zeige ich
euch davon christi zutaten pro 100 gramm
ingwer benutzt man eine prise salz 75
milliliter essig und 50 g zucker bei der
menge ist es so wie gesagt pro 100 gramm
den dir diese menge je nachdem wieviel
ihren ingwer ihr eben habt jetzt sind
wir denn ingo und schälten und zwar geht
es am besten mit einem löffel und da
könnte die schale so ein bisschen ab
reifen und ich mag diesen gara immer
ganz gerne vor allem über den selber
macht kann man selber bestimmen wie
schafft man hin möchte die fischerin
möchte denn da eingelegte ja schon immer
relativ süß und säuerlich und hat etwas
weniger schärfe je nachdem welchen man
eben auch nimmt
die härteren stellen wir nehmen jetzt
mit einem messer weg ich finde irgendwie
dass das aussieht wie ein einhorn da
oben dass honda den kopf und körper und
super ich leite es zu verarbeiten
naja ich bin es trotzdem besser weg der
ingwer fein gehobelt werden das könnte
jetzt entweder mit so einer manuellen
popel machen oder in einer
küchenmaschine ich mache jetzt in der
küchenmaschine und das sollte wirklich
ganz ganz fein werden
es kommt da irgendwo in kochendes wasser
dadurch verliert er ein bisschen schärfe
und je nachdem wie shafir den gerne mögt
könnt ihr ihn jetzt länger oder kürzer
treten lassen
also ich mag die linken war gerne scharf
deswegen koche ich dir jetzt nur zwei
bis drei minuten aber könnten auch bis
zu fünf minuten kochen und das wasser
was anschließend übrig bleibt ist
übrigens nichts zum wegschmeißen sondern
habt ihr einfach ein ingwertee denn ist
auf jeden fall aufheben des tages und
und vor allem sehr lecker von ihnen der
zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt schon mal
zucker reis essig und salz verrühren
dazu mache ich jetzt hier in einer
schüssel an so lange rühren bis sich der
zucker aufgelöst hat
jetzt kann ich nirgendwo abgießen und
wie gesagt ist dieser tee wirklich sehr
gesund das könnte zum beispiel noch
gesehen honig mit dazugeben und zitrone
und james tupper gegen erkältungen oder
im sommer einfach abkühlen lassen ohne
in limonade draus machen
dann kommt es direkt mit zum reiss essig
und zucker und wird jetzt auch gut
verrührt
und jetzt will ich sie in ein glasgefäß
um das schließt den deckel das ist
erstmal abkühlen unter dem kühlschrank
lagern und da muss es dann wie gesagt
eine woche durchziehen
jetzt kommen wir zum sushi reis
eigentlich ist die reise auch wirklich
die wichtigste zutat im sushi nehmen da
der geschmack und die konsistenz nicht
stimmen dann passt eben das ganze nicht
ich habe jetzt dafür 500 gramm sushi
reis und 600 milliliter wasser je
nachdem welche sorte ihr macht braucht
jetzt natürlich mehr oder weniger das
ist jetzt eine ganz gute menge dürfte so
für etwa vier personen auf jeden fall
reichen
jetzt zeige ich euch die zubereitung und
zwar nehmen jetzt erstmal den sushi reis
und waschen denn da hat richtig viel
stärke und man braucht natürlich später
auch die stärke aber alles was
überflüssig ist wird jetzt erstmal mit
kaltem wasser weggewaschen jetzt wieder
reißt so lange gewaschen
bis das wasser unten klar ist
jetzt kommt der reis in einen großen
topf und normalerweise also die japaner
machen das zumindest so die nehmen
einfach nur reiskocher aber so oft mache
ich nicht reisgerichte deswegen lohnt
sich das bei mir nicht aber falls ihr
zum beispiel jede woche zweimal so viel
macht würde ich euch ein raise woche
empfehlen denn dann geht das ganze viel
einfacher da kommt das wasser mit dazu
also kaltes wasser ganz wichtig und
jetzt wird das ganze aufgekocht bei
höchster stufe
und sobald der reise koch zusätzlich den
deckel drauf schaltet die hitze auf zwei
herunter und lass ihn dann für 15
minuten quellen
während bereits jetzt noch gab werde ich
jetzt schon mal den essig vorbereiten
und zwar weder reist dann mit einem
sushi zu an gemacht das kann man
entweder fertig kaufen
das sieht dann so aus also das ist schon
reichlich mit drin zucker um salz oder
man bereitet ist selber zu und auf diese
menge brauche ich dann später so etwa 80
bis 100 milliliter von diesem schuh sie
zu
und dass er daneben damit abgeschmeckt
ich werde es jetzt selber machen und
zwar brauche ich für das so ski zu 100
gramm reis essig 80 34 kannst jetzt gebe
ich die drei zutaten einfach in einen
kleinen topf da wird das kurz aufgekocht
dann lösen sich zucker und salz ganz gut
auf da kann ich es auch direkt wieder
unternehmen
jetzt habe ich direkt nach dem reihe
sitzt in 15 minuten frei und man sieht
jetzt auch der hat die komplette
flüssigkeit aufgezogen das heißt es
jetzt auch fertig
und jetzt kommen etwa 80 bis 100
milliliter von diesem session zu mit da
rein und dann gut durchrühren und an der
stelle können jetzt auch direkt mal
abschmecken und jetzt fühle ich den reis
direkt um in eine größere schale damit
er schön abkühlen kann ohne verarbeitet
ihnen dann bei etwa zimmertemperatur
dafür danke ich ihnen jetzt noch mit
einem tuch ab da nimmt noch die
restfeuchtigkeit weg und jetzt bei
zimmertemperatur lagern nicht im
kühlschrank und sobald der abgekühlt ist
gibt's eigentlich direkt weiter
der reiz ist jetzt abgekühlt auf
zimmertemperatur
das kann ich ihnen weiterverarbeiten und
zwar werde ich einen teil weit lassen
und den anderen fertig ein und zwar mit
rote bete saft und zwar nehme ich dafür
einfach diesen foren und rote beete saft
100 prozent und dafür nehme ich jetzt
aber handschuhe denn und sonst sagen
auch später rot ende so jetzt je nachdem
wie viel ihr einfärben wollte neben den
fertigen reis den gebe ich jetzt in der
extra zuschüsse und das dürfte jetzt
erstmal reichen
und dann kommt da der saft einfach mit
dazu da gibt natürlich auch ein bisschen
geschmack ab es ist schön mit den händen
vermengen dann seht ihr auch schon dass
es reicht und das solltet ihr aber am
besten am tag vorher schon zu bereiten
damit der saft auch noch aufgezogen
werden kann und damit der reise neben
wieder schön klingt und so sieht es dann
im vergleich aus als du denn hier habe
ich schon gestern vorbereitet da ist
richtig schön eingezogen die farbe wurde
auch pink und bei dem sieht man eben das
noch richtig nach den preis will ich
jetzt kurz zur seite und zeigt euch noch
die restlichen zutaten die hierfür das
sushi noch verwende
und zwar habe ich jetzt hier ein paar
nori blätter also diese algen blättern
hier eine gurke zwei paprikas habe ich
etwas größer als bei aok dose frischkäse
und hier habe ich noch lachs zu essen
nämlich jetzt die burg geht die werde
jetzt eine lange dünne streifen
geschnitten und da orientiere ich mich
an diesem nori blättern und zwar
schneide ich jetzt erstmal die gurke
genau in die länge ein bisschen länger
dürfen sie sein
jetzt schneide ich hier streifen da kann
ich es auch flach hinlegen und dann geht
es runter geschnitten aber das
kerngehäuse wird gleich entfernt
die presse kann man direkt mit der
schere einfach abschneiden
ich finde die schmeckt regte sich immer
richtig lecker im social jetzt kann ich
noch den fisch schneiden und zwar habe
ich da jetzt lachs aus der tiefkühltruhe
normalerweise wird versuche immer ganz
frischer fisch verwendet das heißt er
muss heute gefangen werden und dann
aufgeschnitten und dann wirklich sofort
verzehrt werden im sushi da es hier in
deutschland nicht vor der fall ist also
man kriegt denn die halt nichts fisch
frisch aus dem meer
deswegen könnte man natürlich auch einen
von der fischtheke holen diesen meister
23 tage alt durch den transport den muss
man dann aber einfrieren 24 stunden
damit einfach bestimmte keine getötet
werden
und da kann man verwenden ich habe jetzt
hier direkt einen lachs aus der
tiefkühltruhe genommen denn die werden
ja gefangen und direkt auf dem schiff
noch eingefroren
das heißt der ist wirklich ganz frisch
und den nehme ich jetzt und schneit dann
eben auch nicht
jetzt kann ich die sushi direkt rollen
ich zeige euch heute drei varianten
zuerst einmal werde ich mag ihn machen
und dafür nehme ich jetzt die nori
blättern
die sind übrigens so dass sie auf einer
seite glatt und auf der anderen raus
sind also hier oben ist jetzt die raue
und da unten die glatte das sieht man
auch die glatte seite hat sondern glanz
und die raue ist also ich kann es aber
im vergleich nebeneinander legen sieht
man hier die hat ein bisschen struktur
dieser seite und die glatte seite hat
weg diesen schönen glanz für die marke
werde ich die blätter jetzt halbieren
dann sind die nicht so groß
und jetzt braucht ihr zum rollen eine
bambus matte und zwar gibt es das
spezielle sushi matten die sehen auch so
aus aber bei mir ist es nicht mal eine
sushi mathe sondern das war mal so ein
plazet also für so ein untersetzter und
den habe ich jetzt in frischhaltefolie
eingepackt und damit klappt das super
die normalen sushi rollen die sind ein
bisschen kleiner aber es passt auch
wirklich gut wenn sie wisse größer sind
davon ist immer platz jetzt nämlich
einen neuen platz mit der glatten seite
nach unten das heißt raue seite nach
oben jetzt nehmt ihr etwas wasser in die
hände dann klebt der sushi reis nicht so
und jetzt nehmen diese ungefähr 80 gramm
also das ist so ungefähr eine kleine
handvoll die wird jetzt da drauf geklebt
jetzt müsst ihr das schön verteilen aber
oben einen streifen freilassen der
streifen hat ungefähr 1 cm breite und
den reis jetzt schön verteilen immer so
ein bisschen lange 10
und immer wenn es klebt wasser
jetzt lege ich das neue blatt direkt an
den anschlag
und jetzt könnt ihr es film mit was ihr
möchtet ich mache jetzt erstmal
vegetarisch mit gurke kommt die gurke in
die mitte und dann schlag ich jetzt den
teil hier oben ein mit der matte
jetzt drückt es hier einmal fest und
zwar habt ihr jetzt auf drei seiten
druck einmal hier außen vorne hinten und
oben und sei es ein paar mal drüber
streichen und die frischhaltefolie sorgt
übrigens dafür dass eure sushi matte
sauber bleibt
dann wird weitergedreht und fest
gedrückt
nicht so habt ihr dann die erste rolle
und die lege ich jetzt hier mit der
schnittkante nach unten auf eine platte
und so geht's jetzt weiter
und so kann ich sie jetzt zum beispiel
auch mit paprika oder mit avocado oder
auch mit lachs führen
jetzt mache ich eine inside out rolle
das heißt ich gebe jetzt hier wieder
heiß drauf aber etwas mehr und zwar
kommt es jetzt hier auf das neue blatt
aber eben auch ein bisschen auf die
matte und zwar für das stück jetzt so
etwa noch mal um die hälfte weit
herausragen
als um die hälfte weiter alles das neue
blatt ist und damit der abschluss hier
schöner wird nämlich die matte zu hilfe
gelegt die einmal um und tricks fest und
dann ist der abschluss wirklich schön
gerade damit jetzt eine inside out rolle
wird muss das blatt gewendet werden
jetzt nämlich etwas frischkäse ihr könnt
zum beispiel aber auch mayonnaise nehmen
das streiche ich jetzt hier in die mitte
das geht echt super einfach mit einer
palette oder einfach mit einem messer
zum beispiel dann kommen zwei gurken
sticks die kommen jetzt hier als
umrandung außen herum dann mag ich die
total gerne mit kresse
und wer möchte kann jetzt hier zum
beispiel ocado oder auch paprika
einlegen ich nehme jetzt aprica dann
habe ich ein schönes farbkontrast
und jetzt wieder mit der matte rolle und
zwar so erst einmal dann fest drücken
dann geht es wieder ein stück weiter
fest drücken und beim ein drittes mal
man kann die matte hier oben leben und
hier an
dann kann man die rolle nämlich richtig
richtig jetzt lege ich sie hier noch
nach außen und drehen noch mal zu und
kann das hier auch noch schön fest
drücken und nach dem prinzip kann man
auch eine zweifarbige inside out rolle
machen und zwar nimmt man dafür die
hälfte weißen reis und die hälfte roten
reis
jetzt machen wir noch die dritte form
und zwar in isny die werden ohne die
alten blätter gemacht dafür da gibt es
jetzt zwei möglichkeiten ich zeige euch
dass beide einfach erst mal wieder die
hände etwas befeuchten mit wasser dann
nehmen wir ein bisschen reißaus und
formen des jetzt in den händen
und da kann man jetzt zum beispiel lachs
darüber legen
oder ich werde ja auch gleich noch
vegetarisch machen
dies kann man auch beispielsweise mit
der matte formen
da findet man jetzt den reis und gebt
ihm direkt auf der matte dann breite ich
den jetzt hier in der mitte aus das lege
ich die matte drüber und formen damit
die rolle
nicht schneidet sie noch zurecht
das messen wasser tropft und klebt der
reis auch nicht so an
jetzt kann man sie theoretisch zu lassen
oder auch nochmal mit den händen ein
bisschen nach vorne
dann habt ihr auf jeden fall immer die
gleiche große portionen jetzt mache ich
die vegetarischen kiri dafür habe ich
hier etwas spargel gedünstet und auch
schon direkt zugeschnitten und jetzt
habe ich hier noch diese algen blätter
zugeschnitten einfach länglich jetzt
kommen die natürlich wieder mit der
rauen seite nach oben
da kommt jetzt eine geri drauf das mache
ich jetzt so dann zwei spargelstücke
weil die würden ja so jetzt nicht helfen
deswegen kommt das jetzt hier drüber wie
so eine kleine schleifen mit
und der rest verschwindet darunter und
da hat man noch so ein schönes päckchen
jetzt kann ich die sushi bereits
servieren ich habe jetzt hier noch
schwarzkümmel und sesam und zwar wenn
ich da die eine inside out rolle darin
wälzen deswegen für mich die beiden ihr
könnt natürlich auch nur saison oder nur
schwarzkümmel nehmen aber ich finde
kombination richtig schön und da nehme
ich jetzt die weiße rolle und stauchte
hier ein
braucht ihr ein scharfes messer und
etwas wasser ich nehme ich zuerst einmal
diese rolle hier und jetzt macht ihr
immer so eine gleitende bewegung und ich
schneide dir jetzt in acht teile das
heißt ich halte sie zu ernst und dann
einfach nochmal viertel
nun könnte die direkt auf einer platte
setzen
jetzt könnt ihr auch immer mehrere
rollen gleichzeitig schneiden
ich habe übrigens um mir noch so die
richtigen tipps zu holen das
hochschieben im globus gelernt also da
gibt es natürlich sushi theke die hand
ich euch schon auch schon mal gezeigt
und da wird es sicher ganz frisch
gemacht und da war ich dann gab ein paar
tage und habe dort sushi gelernt muss
ich noch immer bei ihm bedanken
ja und zwar bei natalia und bei
ich hoffe ich habe den namen richtig
ja das ist richtig nett
gemeinschaftsrecht rom kg eine suppe
nein
sie arbeitet dort auf ihr und die beiden
sind richtig nett und habe mir ganz
viele tipps gegeben war richtig super
lustig vor allem über das in der mitte
steht und dann sowieso raus rücken kann
von echt spaß gemacht was super okay so
ich bin jetzt fertig ich habe das ganze
hier auf seine tasche angerichtet aber
ich finde es immer schön wenn man so
einzelne platten hat aber moral
ich dachte erst es in die computer
retten möchte ja dann bedienen und jetzt
noch niemand gibt jetzt am besten
einfach selber mit
irgendwie mag magie die magie mag etwas
anderes maxim gorki erheblich denn egal
wie du möchtest
unser team mit roten genau und dann ist
man wie gesagt diese momente sind da ist
man dazu diesen ingwer und dann habe ich
hier was habe das habe ich jetzt selber
angerührt ist was faul aber was habe ich
das abi und jetzt noch sojasauce und ich
mache es immer ganz gerne so ich
vermisse man so ja würfel mit wasabi und
dann denke ich dass ein
ich weiß nicht wie gut ist mark kelly
und so war die zeit als voll
erstens weil ich kann nicht mit stäbchen
essen aussicht ich es so oder ist es
einfach das ist hier ein bisschen wasser
hält kann
so jetzt wird sie jeder japaner dreht
sich im grabe um den wald ist dies auch
nicht möglich also man muss vielleicht
dazu sagen
die nie die rede ist ja schon ziemlich
groß ich glaube die meisten schaffen es
mit einem harten aber ich muss ja
eigentlich eigentlich auch so gern
probiert und zwar weil die massage
richtig aufpassen dass print richtig das
hat so eine komische schärfe ist so eine
richtige monate länger nämlich nicht so
ingo fenster schauen auch kurator
zerstört hat meine sushi rollen die ich
hier die letzten stunden gemacht habe ok
um nächste da muss sogar dlr schreien
und ich glaube ich gut mache noch weiter
probieren ja ich gebe dir gern noch aber
ich möchte auch ein bisschen was für uns
beginnt stuttgart aufheben ja ich bin
gewohnt vegetarische vegetarische hero
mal mit paprika also bei den
vegetarischen merkt man oft gar nicht
dass die vegetarisch sind ich erst jetzt
eigentlich machen die chinesen alles ist
ein japanisches reform osteuropa ja also
ich persönlich mag auch die
vegetarischen am liebsten normalerweise
esse ich nicht so gerne rohen fisch
wobei im schema dies wirklich sehr gerne
also da ist sich nicht gern ja die leute
das war eigentlich so die grundlegende
infos
wir essen auch zum beispiel ganz gerne
mal zwischen mannheim und da gibt ja die
mit dem frittiert und hähnchen usw
dies läge ja genau können wir vielleicht
auch mal machen
jedenfalls war das jetzt mein basic
rezept und drei verschiedene sorten und
ich hoffe euch hat dieses video spaß
gemacht vielleicht versucht ihr euch
jetzt auch mal an sushi ich habe
übrigens immer gesagt es ist kein social
weil ich einfach diesen fisch nicht so
mochte bis dann das erste mal probiert
habe und die ersten mal wirklich
vegetarisch und dann habe ich mich auch
in den fisch rangetraut und sich weg
nicht sehr lecker so machst du mich
einfach immer besser schmeckt wirklich
erst mal ausprobieren
ich bin zum beispiel auch ganz lecker
mit mango innen total gut
nein ich es jetzt auch mit und ich
wünsche ich ganz viel spaß danach machen
und auch einen guten appetit bis zum
nächsten mal